si está inmóvil durante un periodo
prolongado debido a una cirugía embarazo
enfermedad o viaje puede estar en riesgo
de desarrollar una trombosis venosa
profunda tvp la cual es una afección en
donde se forma un coágulo de sangre en
una vena profunda del cuerpo normalmente
en las piernas a diferencia de las
arterias que dependen del corazón para
que haga circular sangre a través de
ellas las venas transportan sangre con
la ayuda de contracciones musculares
mientras uno se mueve o camina las venas
también tienen válvulas que evitan que
la sangre fluya en sentido contrario y
se acumulen en los brazos y piernas
cuando está inmóvil durante un periodo
prolongado la velocidad de su
circulación venosa disminuye por
consiguiente los factores de coagulación
de la sangre pueden provocar que la
sangre lenta se junte
formando un coágulo de sangre o trombo
esta afección se denomina trombosis
venosa profunda tvp
los síntomas comunes de la tvp incluyen
hinchazón de la pierna o de una vena de
la pierna dolor o sensibilidad en el
área incremento en la temperatura de la
piel y piel roja o pálida
en algunos casos de tvp un coágulo de
sangre puede desprenderse de una vena
profunda y unirse al flujo sanguíneo el
coágulo viaja desde las venas profundas
de la pierna a través de las venas del
abdomen
hasta el corazón
y finalmente alojarse en la arteria
pulmonar o en sus ramas bloqueando el
flujo sanguíneo hacia los pulmones
esta afección denominada embolia
pulmonar es muy grave y puede causar
daños permanentes en una parte del
pulmón si el coágulo es grande o si hay
muchos coágulos la embolia pulmonar
también puede causar la muerte
si presenta síntomas de embolia pulmonar
avise a su médico o enfermera de
inmediato estos síntomas pueden incluir
falta de aliento
dolor agudo repentino en el pecho
sensación de debilidad o mareo
latidos del corazón rápidos o
irregulares o tos que produce sangre
para ayudar a prevenir la trombosis
venosa profunda y la embolia pulmonar su
médico puede ordenarle hacer lo
siguiente caminar periódicamente para
evitar que la sangre se acumula en sus
piernas utilizar medias de compresión y
tomar medicamentos anticoagulantes